on this episode India's not here and I
talk startup life
you ask questions
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 1 97 on
the ask gary vee show Stefan hey done me
too man really good good weekend Fantasy
Baseball Draft was this weekend I was a
lot of fun we drafted here right here I
was right there did really well uh
really excited to be back on a normal
show this is slightly a little bit less
normal so first of all India is not
India today why don't you tell the
Vayner nation who you are
hi everyone I'm Sam um I'm Senior
Account Executive at Boehner in Libya
how long have you been here Sam I've
been here for about six months
how's it going it's going great like
super great like super nice and where
are you from I'm from New Jersey
where these friends would love it right
by Edison next you like that you like
Jersey I mean oh you knew that um so Sam
Sam works on a very important account
for me
as some of you might remember if you've
been following my ways this is right
before dailyvee and snapchat so you may
not know this but I went up to Buffalo
late last year in the middle of the
football season by the way so it was
tough territory part of an organization
43 North which has an incredible
incredible program for startups from all
over the world that submitted thousands
and thousands of submissions last year
we worked on it last year Geordi Levy a
good friend of mine is heavily involved
in the in the whole rebirth of Buffalo
and that part of New York and they're
bringing amazing startups to the area
and I got the judge last year the
competition where we saw the best of the
best the last 13 or so startups we wind
old it down and we rewarded a lot of
money a ton of money so this episode is
very much themed for that it's very
personal for me want to get the word out
for all of you there's so many of you
that are building meaningful startups
and I'm very honestly the submission
forms and things that nature take time
so I'm telling you right now that I'm
trying to really help you not waste an
hour like the the filter is pretty real
and actually Sam why don't you give some
more context on some of the nuts and
since you're obviously working on it
above the competition
sure so as Gary said it's an amazing
competition for startups they're
boarding five million dollars to the top
yeah the grand prize is a million and
sort of questions today come in asking
area like what this could do for a
start-up and how this could help you but
beyond that you also get mentorship from
some of the top people the kicker is
they have to move to Buffalo for a year
right well I know that wouldn't not the
whooping I don't know what's happening
with the winners of ours but I know the
year before that company stayed there
and so they can stay or leave eventually
but obviously it has to go there in the
beginning right obviously Buffalo
prefers you like fresh set up shop right
and it's amazing some of the companies
that are down there and like before I
had no contacts Buffalo before working
on this account it's like an incredible
area for startups in general 100%
incubator space I mean I think a lot of
you that know and a lot of you've
emailed me in whether it's Chattanooga
Tennessee where we have an office or
Columbus Ohio or just seems like every
city is clearly recognizing the need for
digital driven company talent in their
ecosystem is incredibly powerful that's
the new Industrial Revolution so I've
been very passionate about it I got to
spend a lot of time you notes this is
tough for me because I hate the Buffalo
Bills and I know like it just it is what
it is but it's amazing how much I love
the people involved in this organization
the it was probably one of the better to
day events that I've spent time in and
I'm excited that we're involved again
couple things that I don't know this is
you know I don't know these kind of
things
our company people that are watching
right now if this gets passed on to you
know startups of friends couple quick
questions one your startup can be in
motion like you can be in a place where
you can use this million dollars and
this is my advice is why I'm asking this
is a setup you can use that million
dollars instead of going getting funding
from somewhere else so many of you have
companies of getting tens of thousands
of emails a month of people to have
companies that are looking to raise
money that already have some traction I
highly recommend those companies enter
this competition because you can
subsidize that grand prize for that you
won't dilute your company as much plus
instead of wasting all that time
pitching bc after bc it's in this
ecosystem but you have to have the
scrappiness in the mentality of willing
to go and understand that you're moving
to Buffalo for that year and the
competition number two because I know
it's the kind of rounds up later in a
year is there a link that's F on and I
could have not like our people ready to
submit now when's the submission period
started it started already okay um and
it ends May 31st
oh crap so we need to get it yeah okay
so everybody like we can have the
link-up already go yeah great anything
else okay well are you ready to read
some questions good let's do it Taylor
asks how does a startup know when to add
staff what positions are most critical
to line up first so Taylor and by the
way before I get into your answer Taylor
obviously this is a startup themed
episode in honor the 43 north
competition Taylor I think that um
there's a lot of ways to go about this I
think you reverse engineer the founders
of the company so there's a lot of
things that are needed financial
understanding is needed marketing
understandings needed product
understanding is needed there's a lot of
needs when you're a small company I
think what you need to do is first you
hire as soon as you can afford to wait
too many like there's startups that I
know that are literally paying their
founders and CEOs way too much money and
because they want to take the money home
I mean you've got to start spending it
to invest in your business but not more
than you have and so if you make you
know thirty or forty thousand dollars a
year as an entrepreneur that's plenty
you're building an asset for yourself
for the rest of your life it's better
than making a hundred so you can take
that seventy thousand and go and hire
your head of marketing hire a project
manager hire whatever needs you have who
to hire is actually quite easy in my
opinion you hire around the thing that
you believe you most need that you
yourself can't most provide I don't hire
salespeople very quickly in my companies
I don't hire you know HR people very
quickly we didn't have a HR department
or a sales staff for the first five of
the seven years of vaynermedia and
everybody thought that was so crazy
because there were the things that I did
those are things that I could do with my
hustle but we did have a CFO and a legal
person very quickly over our means
because those were shortcomings I think
AJ could have probably learned it on the
job but those are things we didn't have
as much up so I think when you hire
first is the thing you need to round out
your team with even if it's not let's
see sales is
more important than legal but you're
great at sales I think you still fix
legal even though it's less in priority
because by doubling down on a person
you're still zero here and you might
just gain 20 to 50 percent here where
maybe your hustle and your efforts can
just be the part that gains and so I
think sometimes people say well sales is
the number one thing for this company
and even though I'm great at sales I'm
gonna hire a second sales person and
we'll get to that I find it to be a
vulnerability I would say up your game
by 20 to 40 percent and allow you to
fill some of the other needs that could
become vulnerabilities
I'm your team cool videos too it comes
from ACE oh I know this guy ace just so
you guys have a very nice job face was
one of the finalists one of my favorite
fire fleas were look how swaggy he looks
this guy's awesome you're about to see I
loved
he was probably the standout personality
for me in the competition
hey Gary a sweet hey was tonight a
really good question you another BCC
into one of deals come across your plate
the question is what are two or three
things
stand out from all the other ones thanks
Gary got it
it's gonna be a good episode we haven't
done we haven't done a lot on startup
stuff it's been very entrepreneurial
it's gonna be good
ace what stands out ironically is the
way I just set up you in this question
for me the jockey the the she and the he
that are pitching me are normally 80% of
the equation so many of you have heard
that you know the classic story of like
basically I knew I was going to marry my
wife five minutes in if I'm willing to
make my biggest life decision predicated
on my intuition I'm definitely going to
let it do something so secondary like
investing and so the same way I hire
like I'm a funny hire like everybody
used to want to um actually watch this
Alex Alex is I ironic timing this is
Alex Klein Alex get in here you're
making an appearance on the askgaryvee
show this is literally crazy timing
because I was about to say something
that is a story that involves you Alex
crime my brother-in-law was his brother
who happens to do a ton of recruiting
with from his own firm for Boehner is
this true or false because we got to go
fast Sharon I don't want you to like I
feel like you would take up too much
time if I'm sure if all true or false
did you Alex remember had a recruiting
firm that would make a commission if we
were to play somebody got it that's how
his business works true or false you
liked it better when I interviewed
people because I almost hired everybody
versus everybody else at vaynermedia
true and false okay go ahead because
well I think it works out better I think
long term for everybody I think it works
out better with this kind of process
it's in place now right instead of me
just shooting the man just because yeah
but from afar I can make a DNA let's
make let's make let's get to actually my
point is it true that I'd be more likely
to hire somebody after a seven-minute
meeting and just make a decision 100%
okay cool
that's right thanks for later see you
later all right big Mets loss opening
day sorry
Oh David right uh so the funny thing is
you happen to be walking by I love the
serendipity of all that that's the
punchline I hire in four seconds I I
make decisions based on my intuition but
a start-up has to have an idea in a
genre that I like if you're doing
eSports if you're doing VR B to B if
you're doing a fully integrated brand
direct to consumer consumer
which goods if you're doing things I
believe in and I like your style very
quickly then that's something that I'm
going to be open up to if you have those
same things and I don't like your style
I'm definitely out and if you have
something that's not in my wheelhouse
that I believe is going to make money
but I'm in love with your style I can be
intrigued and sold into you so the ones
that get my deals are usually genres I
like and I like the jockey the CEO I
believe that she and he can navigate
even changing it along the way because
that's what happens to startup that's my
intuition some people that get my money
is not to really know that much about
the space or passion about it but I'm
but I think you're a superstar you'd
have to be even better than the first
group the things that don't get are
things that I don't like or I don't like
the genre and definitely I don't like
the individual I don't feel like they're
gonna see it through thanks ace let's
give me - Alex Klein making an
appearance huh it's a lot of new
characters on today's show from Niall
Niall Niall asks ideas alone can only
get you so far
but once you've gotten off the ground
what does an investor need to see to
advanced in a startup well I think
investors we all act very differently
there's some black and white binary
investors who are looking for Matt to
add up right like here your sales here's
your cost of acquisition you know your
monthly burn like just pure financial
decisions and then other investors are
betting on the hyper growth you've gone
from zero to fifty thousand users in two
minutes
I predict that you're going to go to
five million users you're not making any
money but you're going to grow faster
and you're going to hit a home run and
I'm ok with the burn and the financial
issues because you're going to raise
more money as you get bigger and bigger
and so you're betting on hard core
financial principles or you're betting
on the anticipation of high hyper growth
I think one thing to keep in mind is
once you're off the ground people have
something to judge so I think a lot of
people get away with invest in getting
investors just on ideas which i think is
a vulnerability to the whole ecosystem
but it's funny I've always been
fascinated by companies that are making
money and have a year's worth of data
often times aren't as expects II as the
idea because investors get romanced in
the up side without any practical data
vs. well I already know what you've done
for
a year and so I think a lot of
youngsters have been crafty and getting
investment before they have a product
which I think has led to a much higher
return of failures which I think people
need to become more practical and and so
I think you know just for everybody and
for you once you have some data be
prepared to be grilled a little bit more
because people have something to judge
and I think that's great and healthy and
needs to be more of the standard okay
Caitlin and Kristina yes I remember
these gals they were awesome HR I love
it
hi Gary for an early-stage startup that
just received five hundred thousand six
hundred thousand or a million dollars in
capital what are the critical things
they should be looking to address these
guys have a great company let's make
sure we link up both aces and their
company and plums company in my
description Stefan make sure he team up
with Sam under that um but look I mean
first and foremost you don't want to
blow it I mean the amount of people that
have blown through their five and six
hundred million dollars in cash because
they didn't have a strategy of what they
were gonna do with the money is
unbelievable it's unbelievable how much
cash and wallet is just burning for so
many startup founders it's quite sad so
I think you have to have a real plan for
it and then again no different than the
first question on this episode you have
to have a strategy on where you're going
to deploy it what are your biggest needs
to me I like to invest in things that
bring back dollars in the in the mid
term I don't need a short term but I
don't need the longest time I think
sometimes people - and you know 20 ideas
a [ __ ] until execution I like to say a
lot because I think most founders get
caught on one side or the other
some founders take five hundred thousand
dollars and they want that 500 thousand
to make them eight hundred thousand it's
all transactional sales conversion other
founders start thinking about what their
company needs in three years in three
years we're going to need video editing
software so let's buy that now and
didn't even get to those three years and
by the time you you know by the time you
spend all that money that was what
created the scenario of you never
getting to those three years from now so
I think much like marketing in the year
that you live in day trading attentions
in my market
principles I deploy in my operating
principles what is the most important
thing with that money right this second
that isn't short-term sales turn to 500
to 600 thousand but what is not the
we're going to need this in three years
so let's spend it and by the way
furniture and rent and all these things
that's where people waste money like AJ
and I started this company in in a in a
in a conference room of another company
like like Vayner like this is not a
super fancy office right yeah it's good
I'm happy about that like we got I mean
this is actually pretty fancy compared
to where we were a year ago so like you
know people just waste money on a lot of
things that don't matter now it can't be
so screwed up in here that people don't
want to come here but you know we don't
need like eight thousand dollar recliner
chairs for everybody and that's what a
lot of startups do it's crazy
they like spend more time and energy on
like how fancy the coffee machines gonna
be than actually building a goddamn
business
so what do you do with it you better
know what to do with it or your startups
and deep [ __ ] Don't Ask Gary Vee I hate
third-person don't ask me like figure
out what to do with it make it practical
as hell because that money will
disappear fast and the only thing that
will disappear faster is your hopes and
dreams about your business if you don't
know what to do with it you like that I
love it it's real right yeah Jersey
efferent lads asks when assessing the
scalability for a company one of the
things you look for huh you know Zack
I'm not looking for much I'm usually
doing that homework and living that
business life beforehand it's not hard
for me
I don't ever struggle with understanding
oh you know what obviously I don't know
if you noticed in my face there Stefan I
was like thinking about it like I see
what's happening I have such a good
understanding of any kind consumer
dynamics the marketplace the market the
stuff I talked about for the last ten
years of my life a lot of venture
capitalists don't a lot of business
people don't but what I'm really good at
is understanding demand I understand the
customer so I rarely ever struggle with
being like who's gonna buy your thing
like I can make those connections in my
head pretty easily and so I'm not
spending a lot anything is
scalable anything is scalable in theory
because you can either humanely scale it
or you can scale it with technology you
just have to understand if people want
it like do people want mattresses sent
to their home like that's where people
messed up with Casper and those kind of
companies did people want you know uber
you know we thought that was going to be
a one-percent problem when we first
heard it I'm those are early
conversations were like well okay
there's enough rich people like maybe we
underestimated the fact that everybody
wants to buy time didn't understand that
$8 green juice you know like that maybe
didn't seem right to a lot of people
because like who's going to pay that
well people are paying luxury fees now
for their body and their health and so
this generation the kids that you know
and not just the kids I like to make
that joke Millennials and Gen X and
everybody everybody now is more willing
to spend money on their health and
wellness versus an 80 inch screen
television like the 1980s and 90s
mentality of an 80 inch screen
television and the most expensive car
you could get has been replaced with
60-inch television solidly awesome car
but an extra twenty thousand dollars to
buy you know $8 green juices and a
one-year subscription SoulCycle so if
you didn't understand that what's
happening you missed it so you know it's
you know do I think people would pay $50
to go to the movies the answer is yes
has there been an execution that I've
seen that makes me feel like that's the
right bad I haven't yet I know Cubans
got some stuff in his world but like
will people pay $50 to go to movies
absolutely has anybody really executed
the added values that force people at
all income levels to do it not yet but
if I saw somebody pitched me and I'd be
like yes that could happen and so I have
a good understanding for consumer to
understand where things are going so how
do i navigate do I think there's demand
currently or could be bubbled up quickly
to justify value and the life cycle of
that business or is it too early
ventured a VR consumer like do I think
that enough people have VR units at home
to watch seven hours worth of content I
don't and so I'm not investing in the
companies that are
selling based on that reality because I
don't think that's going to happen in 24
months so the punchline is do I believe
the consumers are going to do it in a
short enough period of time so that the
business can actually make money in that
lifecycle cool last yes let's do it
hey Gary what's going on there are a lot
of reasons why startups are flocking to
Silicon Valley in New York but it seems
like emerging startup markets are
becoming increasingly viable what our
cities like Buffalo doing right um that
I don't I don't I think it's becoming
viable because people are all buying
into the dream what they're doing right
is there's more money available to
invest in startups startups are are
simple animals they want expertise
mentorship and money Silicon Valley is
going to win because there's a lot of
developers in San Francisco and things
that major if you're going for big big
tech ideas you need that talent things
that Buffalo in New Jersey and even New
York don't fully have is much the kind
of engineering talent that a San
Francisco has so if you've got an eBay
or a Facebook or you know or a Microsoft
ambition well then you've got a really
debate being out there to have the
engineering talent but in the beginning
these things cancer anywhere Facebook
start in Boston
Pinterest started in Pennsylvania like
you can start them anywhere and more
importantly if you're doing things that
are not grossly reliant on engineering
talent you can do them anywhere in the
things that Buffalo and Cleveland and
Detroit and Columbus Ohio and
Chattanooga Tennessee are doing is that
the rich people in those areas are
starting to write checks to startups and
so then it becomes agnostic and more
importantly there's such a human ation
of city life across the whole country
so you know all these really it's
amazing to see the cities of America go
from places that were seedy ironically
to uh you know having high ceiling lofts
that are a great price and coffee shops
and like cool wine bars like we're
living through a very interesting time
in the city rejuvenation of the United
States and with that comes the natural
artists and tech talent and so I think
what they're doing right is to riding
the wave to be very frank with you
and I also think that there are wealthy
50 60 70 and 80 year olds in those towns
that love their town right that want to
see it succeed
I've even had feelings towards Jersey on
this issue and I'm still fairly young
like when I'm 70 80 I'll definitely want
to make like Edison New Jersey like an
ecosystem of something so I think those
practical behaviors is why it's just the
evolution of the marketplace cool thanks
for doing your part enjoyed it no
worries
question of the day um tell me your
startup story this is an opportunity for
me to let the comments section of both
Facebook and YouTube do so much good for
you some of you have follow me on
Instagram see when I say tell this
community about yourself and it's your
favorite post because you get to talk
about yourself in the comment section
today tell me your startup story aka
tell the world about your startup or be
tell me a story about your sister
startup or how you were part of a
startup in the 90s that failed and this
is what happened or your favorite
startup tell me your startup story and
for all of you that are serious make
sure you click the links below and sign
up for 243 north competition you know I
don't know think I get to be a judge I
don't think I do back to back judges but
hopefully it works out with the Jets
bill schedule or I might just fly up
there for the day
depending on how many of you if any if
any of you make it to the finals I'll
shoot up there and say hey cool you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them